Think back to a perfect cup of morning coffee.
Feel your mug warming your hands awake.
Imagine the sun, how it rises over the mountains
just out the café’s back window.
The birds.
They’re chirping.
Now, isn’t that nice?
On days like these, the world, as far as you
can see it, is in picture-perfect harmony.
Ah, but now let’s consider this.
You order your coffee with an ounce of milk…but
instead, get a splash of political upheaval.
Outside, protests put Frankenstein’s mob
of angry villagers to shame.
Prisoners are being killed by civilians.
Art depicting Jesus hanged with a noose.
Rakes turn to pitchforks.
Pitchforks turn to weapons.
War is all you can think about.
Where did that picture-perfect morning go?
Where are those birds?
Where are you?
You’re in a place where God is leaned on
more than government…but where people are
governed more than God could even know.
But how did you get here?
You might wonder what political events led
to this cluster of chaos.
But what if the answer wasn’t at all in
memory or historical record, but rather on
the end of your index finger.
Yes, your index finger.
That flimsy little digit that’s capable
of so much.
It points to which donut you’d like this
morning.
It draws in the air as you do the math to
calculate how much to tip the cashier.
It flicks off those pesky yellow sprinkles
you still believe taste worse than the rest.
And it hails for a cab when you’re feeling
too full to walk home.
But you thought its role in the course of
history ended there, somewhere between picking
boogers and pointing at shooting stars.
Never did you imagine that that finger could
turn everything into THIS.
You’re at your computer, and instead of
reading the long block of text before you,
you decide simply to wonder: what am I consenting
to with this innocuous click of the mouse?
But never do you dare put in the effort to
find out.
End User License Agreements are blind handshakes.
A deal is struck not by one side’s knack
for negotiation, but rather by the other side’s
propensity for neglect.
To humans, Reading the fine print is more
a phrase than an action.
We’ve all heard it said, but have you ever
seen it done?
From making the bed to mowing the lawn, history
is ripe with chores to complain about.
But what is unique about this chore, reading
End User License Agreements, is that it’s
met with no resistance.
No moans or grievances.
It’s not pushed under the rug nor procrastinated.
It’s an anomaly in itself; it’s simply…
ignored.
Not how you ignore the noise of construction
out your bedroom window at seven in the morning.
That type of ignoring takes a specific effort.
A pillow thrown over your head and pressed
into your ear.
Not how you ignore late-night cravings for
ice cream in bed.
That takes discipline.
We are not talking about an instance that
forces upon us an act of discounting, but
rather an anomaly that by nature is disregarded,
scrolled by, thought nothing of.
And let it be known that End User Agreements
do not have the ego of humans.
They do not take our indifference to them
personally.
In fact, they welcome it, reveling in their
anonymity.
While most EULAs’ agendas are widely understood
to protect software licensors in the event
said software crashes a computer, an unusual
End User License Agreement, SCP-2221, has
higher ambitions.
This contract is not concerned with mitigating
a few lawsuits.
It aspires to more.
As you scroll lower and lower, it subtly seeks
to manipulate the minds, hearts, and souls
of millions, and millions more.
This endless scrolling asked of you is by
no mistake.
Instances of SCP-2221, most often found by
consumers of inexpensive or free software,
are longer than most End User License Agreements,
designed to lull us into a zombie state, not
of reading, but of completing.
The task of reading this particular kind of
contract is so tedious that you no longer
concern yourself with the minutiae between
point a and point b, you just become obsessed
with reaching the finish line.
And it’s within those moments of illiterate
impatience that SCP-2221 knows to strike,
first leading with a jab, better known as
Clause 189, which reads:
"You agree that all worship, prayer, obeisance,
sacrifice, oaths, requests for guidance and/or
intervention, and any other invocations of
divinity directed at any deity or deities
listed in Appendix H.vii will instead be directed
at the Serene Tribune, Friend of the Righteous,
hereafter referred to as 'Amicus.'1 Furthermore,
you agree that this clause supersedes conscious
intent with regard to the direction of the
aforementioned invocations of divinity."
Then SCP-2221 follows up with an ever-formidable
Clause 191:
"You agree that Friends of Amicus LLC2 may
access your consciousness for the purpose
of exerting subconscious influence and/or
temporary control of consciousness for a period
not to exceed seventy-two (72) hours during
any one-week period."
But SCP-2221 doesn’t stop there, not before
delivering one final blow, the knock-out punch,
clause 216:
"You and Friends of Amicus LLC agree that
any attempt to breach or modify the terms
of this agreement, or to bring suit against
Friends of Amicus LLC, must be settled by
arbitration in the Serene Tribunal."3
And once these clauses are combed over and
you hit AGREE, your free will throws in the
towel, surrendering to SCP 2221… and yet,
the battle has just begun.
But first, it must be asked: how do you fight
when you don’t even know who it is that
you’re fighting?
Who is enforcing this contract?
Pro-tip.
If you don’t know what to do with your hands
in a fight, it’s never a bad idea to put
your guard up.
And that’s what The Foundation first did.
When word got out of SCP-2221, strict containment
procedures were put into effect.
Websites believed to host instances of SCP-2221
were isolated for examination, and civilian
users were immediately blocked from such websites.
A team of C-Class personnel were then assigned
the job of maintaining an ongoing search for
websites and software that require users to
agree to an End User License Agreement, and
thoroughly examine all such agreements for
signs of SCP-2221.
C-Class personnel spent hours a day in front
of computer screens scrolling through the
tediousness of every End User License Agreement
they could find.
It was a never-ending job, like picking up
trash on the beach only to return the next
day to find high tide has brought more.
But at least a beach clean-up gives a fleeting
feeling of reward to cherish and cling to.
There is a moment when the sand looks uninhabited,
cleansed of pollution.
There is a moment when the sun sets over the
horizon and you can’t help but think you
contributed a small part to its beauty.
But grinding away at the computer, scavenging
for harmful clauses in EULA’s is far more
taxing than picking up trash.
You don’t need to toil over a littered candy
wrapper to know to toss it in the garbage.
SCP-2221, however, isn’t recognizable at
first glance.
Each End User License Agreement took C-Class
personnel several minutes to analyze before
being able to categorize them as safe or harmful.
Imagine a beach clean-up where each piece
of trash must be sent to the lab before being
thrown away.
That’s the task that was placed upon personnel.
And thus, they eventually came to realize
their efforts to be futile.
With strained eyes and carpal tunnel syndrome,
they officially aborted their original containment
procedures, understanding that the punches
coming their way were too much for any two
hands to block.
Now, while analogizing SCP-2221 to a boxer
throwing blows might be convenient, it only
distances us from the truth of the matter:
SCP-2221 is far more dangerous than any right
hook.
It does not stop for the bell; it is an onslaught
stuck on repeat.
With a defensive stance deemed unsuccessful,
The Foundation had to pivot its approach.
They had to change the way they saw the problem.
And sometimes the best way to learn about
a predator is to study its prey.
Civilians who have accepted the terms of an
SCP-2221 are considered 2221-As, and it’s
in putting these 2221-As under the microscope
of analysis that The Foundation began to find
answers.
This wasn’t The Foundation's preferred method
of study, as they would have rather experimented
within the confines of their labs for reasons
of safety and secrecy.
But they struggled to effectively and accurately
carry out tests to resolve their questions.
Certain classes of individuals, like mentally
incapable people, pre-pubescent children,
and slaves, are all unaffected by SCP 2221,
even if they hit agree.
The Foundation believes this is because they
lack the legal capacity to agree to a contract.
Beyond that, individuals incapable of understanding
the contract - such as those who cannot speak
the language in which it is written, or sleeping
persons made to press the button to agree
to the contract - are also unaffected by the
terms of the agreement.
These limitations have proven extremely disruptive
when attempting to study SCP-2221.
After all, you can’t get too far along with
your research if your lab rats are blessed
with impunity.
And so, the Foundation moved deeper along
their chain of proverbial lab rats, and they
extended their research to D-Class personnel.
The D-Class was instructed to read and agree
to SCP-2221.
This too, however, gave them no return on
their scientific investment.
The reasons for D-Class personnel’s resistance
to contractual obedience is uncertain, but
that doesn’t stop some from speculating.
The Foundation, however, had little time to
wonder.
Their strategy to untangle this mess just
led to more knots, and they needed to straighten
things out.
This time to do so, they decided to move beyond
lab-driven research and focus on studying
populations who have possibly been exposed
to SCP-2221.
When observing populations with frequently
recurring 2221-As, The Foundation noted many
odd, yet consistent, behaviors.
First, they recognized increased voter turnout
and political activism.
People in passing wouldn’t talk about sports
but instead propositions and ideas.
Elections weren’t just days of obligations
marked on calendars; they were anticipated
with enthusiasm.
Their dates were etched in the minds of the
collective, as if no different than The Super
Bowl or New Year’s Eve.
The Foundation noticed populations dense with
2221-As had a palpable energy.
It was like the End User License Agreement
gave them a motor, an engine for action.
If there were social or political issues on
peoples’ minds, they weren’t just accepted
as a consequence of society, they were fought
for.
Cars were just as likely to be stopped by
protestors as they were a red light.
Politics in these areas were primitively efficient.
The system was more condensed.
People wanted something, and they did what
they had to do to get it.
There was no room for the performance of good
manners in this political construction.
If something was seen to be out of line, it
was pushed back in.
Churches began sprouting up like weeds.
Because while political involvement increased
steadily, the authority of religion ran rampant.
A shift in practice was observed.
And it didn’t take a microscope to see it.
Religion was no longer held in the heart,
hidden beneath personal belief, but it was
a statement worn like a designer jacket.
It was a code for living.
A code that 2221-As believed must be enforced.
And so when civilians deviated from religious
law, community punishment came with it.
It was not uncommon to see sinners being shamed
at the center of town squares.
It was not uncommon for them to be ridiculed
and guilted until they felt like nothing at
all.
And while showered with shame they stood frozen
like a statue, erected to remind others of
what happens when they deviate from the law
of God.
But even humans playing statues weren’t
enough to quench 2221-A’s thirst for religious
art.
These highly affected communities were noted
also for their paintings.
From the murals in churches even to the walls
in nurseries, 2221-A dense populations glorified
nooses, and patterns resembling nooses, with
unnerving frequency.
Even in the artwork that emits nooses, you
will notice the necks of the subjects are
slightly red and scratched, presumably to
symbolize rope that had once been there, even
if not there now.
In affected Christian communities you wouldn’t
find records of Jesus nailed to the cross,
but instead hanging by the neck.
However, when observing the works’ creation,
The Foundation noted that the paint strokes
of their studied subjects were not that of
an artist…but a puppet.
There was no noticeable muse guiding their
hand down a path of creative discovery.
There weren’t even any pauses for reflection
or wonder.
The movements were precise but not inspired.
The art seemed to be composed of all wrist
and no heart.
So, if these people really are puppets forced
to perform, the question remains: who is our
puppeteer?
To find out, we have to follow the strings
wherever they run and pull.
And luckily that isn’t too hard, as all
of them lead to the same instance: October
2012, when a densely populated 2221-A community
in a small town, further referred to as POP-044-2221-A,
undoubtedly exposed themselves as living under
the influence of an anomalous force, immediately
recognized as SCP-2221.
In October of 2012, armed mobs attacked Foundation
installations in the town.
Site 614 swiftly contacted the 05 Council
to report the incident.
It was believed that these mobs were not just
violent brutes looking to smash glass, but
that their attacks had a more nuanced motive.
Soon it was apparent that they had inside
information concerning The Foundation, and
they demand that the Foundation surrender
several specific anomalies and mandate that
34 specific members of Foundation personnel
be put on trial.
The October attacks on Site 614 were initially
attributed to the Republic of Letters - a
group of Foundation employees who believe
that the public deserves to know the truth
about what they do.
The group quickly claimed responsibility for
leaking information leading to the disaster.
At this point, The Foundation was not yet
aware of any major 2221-A populations, let
alone POP-2221-A, and thus the Republic of
Letters' claims were believed, at least until
there was good reason to question them.
Examination of computers at Site 614 revealed
that many personnel had been using software
hosting an instance of SCP-2221.
The consensus within the Foundation then shifted
to the belief that the leaked information
came from Foundation personnel, having been
subverted by the Friends of Amicus - the group
behind SCP-2221.
It remains unknown whether the failure to
find and report this instance of SCP-2221
was due to negligence…or deliberate sabotage.
To find out, Site 614 personnel were detained
for examination.
Field agents from Site 115 and Site 621 were
sent to the affected area under the command
of Site Director Susan Pritchard to observe
and report on the local 2221-A population,
POP-044-2221.
Under the manipulation of an anomalous End
User License Agreement, 2221-As go to war
with local prisons.
And while we call it a war, they might call
it a fight for justice.
Because in their mind, this onslaught is justified.
But justified might be the wrong word here.
It implies logic.
But there is no discernable reasoning here.
When POP-004-2221 ambushes the cells of criminals,
it’s not for reason, but rather an obligation.
It is an order from elsewhere.
These attacks don’t look mechanical or robotic,
yet there is a clear sense that buried within
an impassioned rage is something enforcing
it.
The 2221-As might best be compared to horses
running a track.
Surely, they are by nature powerful animals
who enjoy high speeds, but would they really
act like this if not for the contrived structures
of The Kentucky Derby.
So, this is to ask: Who runs the fastest,
the horse in the freedom of the fields?
Or the one being whipped?
The answer presents itself to local security,
as they go head-to-head with the violent determination
of 2221-As, led by their anonymous commander.
It was a taxing battle, but security forces
were able to repel most of the attacks and
limit the damage.
However, prisons in the area didn’t have
such luck and were overrun by fervent mobs.
Prisoners at both locations are dragged outside
and murdered, even those prisoners who have
committed the most minor of crimes.
College students peer pressured into petty
vandalism found themselves sentenced to death
by the hands of 2221-As.
A woman sentenced for flicking a lit cigarette
into the snow was killed for it in plain sight.
Over the course of the next four months, even
more drastic changes in the religious practices
of the local Sunni Muslim majority were observed.
Local mosques begin announcing the call to
prayer eight times per day instead of the
traditional five.
Decorative nooses were seen hanging in doorways,
often adorned with colorful cloth in elaborate
patterns.
Several imams believed to be instances of
2221-A are noted to add an additional prophet,
“Sadiq,” to the traditional Islamic list
of prophets.
But when pressed for additional information
on Sadiq, these imams act confused, and they
deny knowledge of any such name.
By April 2013, affected communities began
sounding the call to prayer up to thirty times
per day.
With little time left for other activities,
attacks on Foundation installations ceased.
POP-044-2221-A distributed print versions
of the SCP-2221 contract, thereby converting
nearly all adult members of affected communities
into instances of 2221-A.
The Foundation acted quickly.
Field agents quarantined towns inhabited by
POP-044-2221-A, and unaffected civilians were
evacuated into Foundation custody.
The frequency of 2221-A calls to prayer continued
to increase until prayer became constant among
the entirety of POP-044-2221-A. Between May
24 and June 6, every known member of POP-044-2221-A
expired from exhaustion and dehydration, bringing
the outbreak to a tragic end.
Recently discovered instances of SCP-2221
have an addition to Clause 217: "By reading
this clause, members of any organizations
listed in Appendix K.iv agree to go [BEEP]
themselves."
The SCP Foundation was one of the organizations
listed, along with the Federal Bureau of Investigation,
the Republic of Letters, and several other
groups of interest and governmental organizations.
Personnel who had read Clause 217 were isolated
and kept under examination.
The addition had no discernible effect, least
of all a literal one.
It is believed that Clause 217 is merely a
taunt, rather than an info hazard or legally
binding addition to the document.
However, supervisors are to make weekly reports
on the behavior of Foundation personnel who
have read modified versions of Clause 217.
Being turned into a murderous religious zealot
in one thing, being forced into an act of
unpleasant self-coitus is quite another…
Now go check out “SCP-029 - Daughter of
Shadows” and “SCP-053 - Young Girl”
for more anomalies that’ll drive you to
do terrible things!